I think Mr Beast is one of the creators
that's also starting to understand this
power of this uh reputation that you've
built of like people trust you like they
love you
to do cool stuff they trust that you put
your heart and soul into a thing yeah so
like and they feel your pain and the
struggle too you know like if a product
like for example say the everyday
calendar like there was issues in
manufacturing stuff like this but it was
hot yeah it would feel the pain of that
and there was still support I mean that
that's the beauty of it when you have
the actual person right there struggling
with their with their lows and highs
that's a decision that I made really
early on where I was like the yet store
is supported by me but it's separate
from me it's not merchandise you don't
have to know who I am or care about who
I am to be interested in this product
and if you go on the website
yes that story plug uh it's like it's
I'm on the about page
dot store uh like you have to go to the
about page to find anything about me
like it's definitely not like this is
the most brand and I think anybody who's
followed me for a long time will see
that like my personality is sprinkled
into it but it's still like clean off of
me and I think that's also because I
wanted something that was separate from
me because I
I'm also running out of narcissism
believe it or not like I don't feel like
I wanna I don't want it to be about me
and I want it to be something that can
also run independently of me and doesn't
like I want to be able to retire my face
and still do like the other stuff
because I think it's fun but I don't
want that to be the core of it